[Music]
all right
here we are back again uh tell me if the
audio
is messed up yeah we're still kind of
messing with this audio
yeah i don't know what happened like i
said why i had to change the settings
all of a sudden because they were fine
before
but you know how [ __ ] happens yeah so
this is uh this is a flick review it's
probably a flick is it a flick or is it
a movie
um it's somewhere between flick and
movie i guess i would put it in
somewhere in that gray area i didn't
even see it i didn't get to see it i
think you saw parts of it but you were
kind of interested
i think at the time well you were out in
the gym or something it was
all right yeah yeah because because i
said well we have to watch a new movie
for the review and then you just went
out in the gym i said i want to hear
that [ __ ]
i probably didn't hear it so i said okay
well i'll just watch it yeah
uh yeah so this is another new one
actually like netflix has been adding a
lot of new horror movies i guess because
like october is coming up
so this is another kind of a ghost story
urban legend the
kind of uh asian horror film called the
bridge curse
uh this is actually from taiwan
this one you know what's really weird is
i was watching this movie and
i'm imagining um i don't know because
i'm not
from an asian country but i'm imagining
that some of the urban legends that were
talked about in that korean movie we
were talking about the other day go adam
but anthology um because one of them in
particular like turned up in this movie
too
in almost the exact same iteration which
i thought was very strange
there was like one scene near the end of
the bridge curse
where these two girls are like running
downstairs like in a
school or a dorm or something and they
keep um
they keep like repeating the same like
they're in the stairwell between the
second and third floor
and then they keep repeating it like
they can't go down anymore yeah and the
same thing happened in
goadam which i thought was so that must
be a thing
yeah it must be it must be like an urban
legend or something that they have
or just a tradition that's what i'm
thinking the thing is though is that
that was korean and this one here looked
like it was taiwanese
it is taiwanese yeah because there was
there was now
now that you're talking about it's
coming back to me with what which one it
was
the the um it was typical upper
middle um quality asian production
you know like like a good korean
movie um that's what it looked like then
and the tone
very much just like a korean horror
movie really but
it's time yeah and like i said if you're
into asian horror you probably like this
it's nothing special it's like nothing
you know to write home about but um it
was you know pretty entertaining yeah it
was
it was pretty good it was well shot um
you know it was kind of like
you know you know how much they love to
to do like the urban legend the ghost
story type of stuff
this is basically based around an urban
legend
that that there's this bridge and this
girl was on the bridge and like her
boyfriend broke up with her or something
and she
jumped off or something like that and
now like
her spirit haunts the bridge so like
what you do is you go to the bridge at
midnight
and there's 13 steps there but at
midnight when you walk up them
there's actually 14 steps like there's
an extra and so you walk up the steps
and then if you turn around
then the ghost kills you so basically
there's a whole bunch and i didn't
really
uh twig onto this until like a little
bit into the movie because it's a little
the beginning of it is a little
uh scatter shot because it kind of
starts out as like a found footage
type of thing so it's kind of like found
footage but then there's like it's like
a regular movie in there too so it kind
of goes back and forth between the two
things
so apparently what's going on is that
there's um
a group of students who are you know
live streaming
uh being out there like doing this you
know urban legend thing which you're not
supposed to do
and then there's like also an
overlapping timeline of like a
journalist
in 2020 who is going back and like
researching these student deaths that
happened
there was like there was one that
happened in 2016 and when it happened in
2012
and then like as it goes on it gets like
more complicated and i was getting
confused as to like what year we were in
because it kept like switching back and
forth you know what i mean yeah you know
eastern
storytelling is a little different it's
not the normal three-act thing you know
talk about sometimes though
it's just like watching anime sometimes
that [ __ ] gets a little convoluted
yeah i mean i figured it out by the end
but it wasn't um
it wasn't to the same extent of like say
the like the original grudge or
something like that where it was just
like cyclical
it was a little bit like that because
like at the beginning
they kind of show like this found
footage part of these particular
students and
it was either i think it was 2012 like
the first student and them doing it and
then like later on they kind of showed
it again but from their perspective
instead of from the outside perspective
of the
live stream so so i was sitting there
going wait a second this
happened already like what's now we're
seeing it from like a little different i
don't know it was really weird
so it like took me kind of a little
while to like catch the wave of it i
guess
but after uh after i got into it like i
said it wasn't
um you know i didn't love it but it was
like
entertaining enough for me to like sit
through the whole thing and like
you know see what was gonna happen at
the end had kind of a little bit of a
twist ending but i think
um i kind of called it so yeah i i you
know like i said
i had other things going on at the time
but i did i did sample the quality
it's typical it's typical east asian
decent stuff that's i don't want to talk
bad about it there's problems
with them they kind of look japan
korea taiwan
and even china kind of they they kind of
fall and they
they kind of fall into the same trap
that the [ __ ] italians used to fall
into
where they do something good and they
say you like that well we'll do that
again oh you like that well we'll do
that again we'll do it again we'll so
they end up being kind of samey yeah
that's the thing with these movies even
though they're from totally different
countries
it feels like the same movie well i mean
it looks like they have like a lot of
the same folklore and a lot of similar
legends and so and they like
movies based on urban legends and based
on these particular
kind of kind of folkloric ghost stories
so i can see how there's a lot of
overlap
it might be too and i'm not maybe
somebody that has lived in asia or knows
anything about it their film industry
can tell me
but it could be that those are just the
ones that are selling to u.s
markets right um so it might be there
might be like a whole panoply of like
different types of movies over there but
it's like they don't really sell them
because
us horror audiences tend to like
the asian films that are like asian and
horrory yeah you know so they're gonna
get the asiany ones
yeah that's what i mean where are the
ones that are most like the you know
with the good
girl with the long hair and [ __ ] i don't
really i don't know if that's the case
but like i said it might be like a
biased sample
i don't know but like i can
the korean the korean zombie movies are
all kind of feeling a little samey
the ones that were happening in the in
in the medieval in medieval korean times
did you notice that they were all failed
that's really weird because yeah we
we did um we did like two different ones
yeah well one of them was a series
yeah and then one of them was a movie
there were differences in quality
we liked the series best i did like the
series the movies weren't as good
yeah the movie was good but it wasn't as
good yeah but it was it's really weird
that it was like so similar and it came
out
like around the same time like it had
almost the same it was like thematically
it was the same it was set at the
same time period um it had like a lot of
the same it was just really weird and i
don't know if they did that on purpose
you don't know if it's sad like you said
sample bias or what it's just that we
you never really see anything come out
of left
field and when it does it stands out and
then they
then it seems like a a bunch of other
ones come out that are kind of based on
that
yeah coming from left it's come almost
kind of like they fall like they're
following trends
well yeah which which us movies do too i
mean every country's movies do that
but it feels like it's real strong yeah
from from that part of the world
like you know something becomes a fad
and then for a couple years maybe even
in a decade they're all kind of like
that
at least the ones we're getting which is
weird because it seems like the asian
horror boom
was kind of like 90s early 2000s like
particularly after the ring came out
like ringu
and the original grudge and stuff like
that so i do feel like
but it's still kind of hitting that same
stuff where it's like they're always
kind of like
revenge stories urban legend stories
like the ghost is almost always
like a girl or a woman like with long
black hair and like a nightgown and
black eyes and like all wet and [ __ ] you
know i remember one time
a a japanese one came out from left
fields called tetsuya iron man when it
first came out it was like wow what the
[ __ ] was that
that's in our box is it for one of these
wow one of these and i never really saw
a copy of that
maybe they did start copying that you
know but maybe it never became a trend
trend in japan but that one stood out
that was like something that
like you know like that was almost kind
of like uh something out of
i don't know did you ever see um uzumaki
no that was kind of cool that was based
on a manga but it was kind of it was
like um
it was real weird and like real
unsettling it was basically about a town
that was obsessed and or possessed by
spirals right it was a little bit
lovecraftian
i have to say but remember that top
remember that one that came from
thailand
and um it was kind of out of left field
i enjoyed it it was real low budget
but it was it had a lot of heart and it
was about that damn
time that that thailand or that thai
vampire where the it was a vampire woman
her head would and her head comes off
yeah
i love that that's like probably my
favorite world legend yeah
i can't remember the name of it either i
think we reviewed it yeah it was low
budget as hell but it was like yeah it
was awesome
yeah it's like her head pops off with
like all the [ __ ] dragging off of it and
stuff
yeah terrible cg that's messed up i
remember having terrible cg maybe it
wasn't this bad
it wasn't that bad but it wasn't all
that great it was like on par of like
[ __ ] you know what i mean uh sci-fi
channel
yeah but it was it was good it was it's
almost kind of like you know
what's uh what's that studio that did
nazis to the center of the earth and all
the
asylum asylum like an asylum flick yeah
it was yeah it was about that quality
yeah
which you know it's not terrible but
it's not the best yeah but it was
but it was foreign and it was well
written yeah so marquez is koyana
scotsie a film
yeah i would call that a film i like
koianna scotty though
um and then beth says what is it with
asian horror and water though
see that's another thing that i've
wondered and there was a large water
component in the bridge curse too not
only because it was a bridge which is
over water
but all of the um if you like got killed
by the curse
like basically you would they would find
you like drowned like somewhere like one
dude was like drowned in a bucket like
one dude
one woman was drowned in like one of
those big like water tanks like [ __ ]
elisa lamb was and stuff like that so
and there's always that thing with like
all the big black hair like coming out
of the drain and
what do they what do they have against
women with long black hair oh they all
have long black hair
and it probably goes down in the drain
and they got to clean hair balls out all
the time well mine does that too and
it's like that
upsets them oh i just put traino down in
there though
well there was one scene in the bridge
curse where like the guy was like he
dropped his necklace and it went down
the drain like
all the uh all the spigots came on like
in the bathroom
and he dropped his necklace down in the
water and he was like trying to get it
and it was going down the drain
and then he pulls up this big like you
know thing of black hair and i was like
big deal that's like my shower like
every day
because of this [ __ ] mop up here and
like [ __ ] tons of it fall out so it's
like that's not scary to me well it's
scary in the sense that i don't want to
clean it but it's not scary as in like
haunting
you know what i mean yeah but yeah so
anyway
uh so yeah if you like asian horror like
i said this is
it's kind of more of the same but if
you're in the mood for that
then you could certainly do a lot worse
i thought it was pretty entertaining
it's had some kind of creepy [ __ ] going
on in it
so you know um this isn't like too long
today just because
we have a bunch of other stuff we got to
do so uh we'll cut it short i guess
a little bit early um but we will be
back tomorrow probably talking about
another movie because i found one on
tubey that looks very
interesting that i kind of want to watch
later on
and uh hopefully that's good when you
talk about it looked kind of cool
so uh we'll talk about it tomorrow so we
will talk to you guys again tomorrow
oh oh i forgot i forgot um we got a new
uh patron okay named uh shane nicole so
we just got that we just got her uh come
on today she sent me a very nice message
so thank you very much i'm so glad i
remembered to say that before we ended
it
although i probably would remember more
but yeah so um we will
talk to you guys again tomorrow and uh
thanks for stopping by as usual
bye